two weirdos had a viral meltdown in
Central Park and now one of their lives
is ruined then for the first time ever
Twitter fact checks President Trump on
voter fraud and for the seven zillionth
time what Trump said turns out to be
true and the facts check turns out to be
a lie the mainstream media get caught in
more coronavirus hypocrisy and in
Washington State gunshot victims get
added to the kovat death toll all that
and more I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
you saw the video there was no way to
miss the video going around the internet
yesterday if you did miss it we will
play it for you it was this interaction
in Central Park between the woman who
was walking her dog and the guy who
starts filming her and then the woman
has a meltdown and that the guy also
kind of has a meltdown I want to know
but will we will play it if you haven't
seen it yet but I want to know just
right off the bat who do you think was
in the right both of these people are
being called Carens
you know the term Karen initially it
meant a middle-aged white woman who's
very nosy and tells you your business
and gets involved in your affairs now it
transcends race and sex it refers
basically to everybody which of the
Karen's was in the right which of them
was in the wrong we will get to that in
one second because I think most people
are getting this completely wrong and I
was pretty shocked and appalled by that
video but first I got to thank our
friends over at ring you know it's very
hard to even remember what life was like
before ring rim ring is so terrific we
are home more than usual these days and
it's still hard to keep a close eye on
things more deliveries mean more boxes
left unattended and more opportunities
for packages to go missing a lot can
happen outside our front doors and we
are not always free to check on things
in person with ring you can keep your
home safe no matter where you are you
could be at home you'd be the office you
could be on vacation you'd be anywhere
you can check in on it ring is on a
mission to make neighborhoods safer
their home security products are
designed to give you peace of mind
around the clock you know I I give ring
out as a housewarming gift to friends of
mine unfortunately there was one friend
of mine that I had not yet given ring to
guess what happened to him the other day
he got his laptop stolen right out of
his apartment I should have given him
ring earlier and I'm certainly telling
him to go get it now get a special offer
on the ring welcome kit when you go to
ring.com slash Noel's the welcome kit
includes video ring video doorbell 3 and
chime Pro it's all you need to start
building custom security for your home
today go to ring comm slash Knolls
that's ring.com slash Noles
I'll set the scene for you in Central
Park there's a woman walking her dog
there is a man who is bird-watching but
he's really people watching because he
starts getting involved in this woman's
business I will refer to her as ms Karen
I will refer to him as mr. Karen so MS
Karen is walking her dog and she's got
the dog without a leash
so mr. Karen decides to get very nosey
and tell Miss Karen to put a leash on
her dog Ms Karen then says she doesn't
want to put the leash on her dog so Mr
Karen like a creep says okay well then
I'm gonna do something that you're not
gonna like very much reaches into his
bag pulls out doggy treats doggy treats
that this guy only had so that he could
lure other people's dogs away because he
was so irritated when the dogs didn't
have leashes so Mr Karen pulls out doggy
treats to lure Ms Karen's dog away MS
and I think the exact words that mr.
Karen said according to him were I'm
going to do what I'm going to do and
you're not gonna like it which is it's a
pretty weird thing to say when you're
isolated with somebody in a park
especially if you're a man and she's a
woman
then MS Karen loses her mind I have
caught you up we have set the scene now
take a listen to what ensues please
don't come close to me please please
call the cops please call the cops
I'm gonna tell them there's an
african-american man threatening my life
please tell them whatever you like
excuse me
I'm sorry I'm and there's a man he is
recording me and threatening me and my
dog there is an african-american man he
is recording he threatened myself in my
dog thank you okay so obviously this
woman behaving absolutely hysterically
but the guy was behaving hysterically
too
they are both Karen this is mr. and Miss
Karen I think they should get married
they should live unhappily ever after
mmm everyone is focusing on how wrong
this woman was and they're calling her
all sorts of things she's a racist she's
terrible
she's gotta have her life ruined and no
one's focusing on what a weirdo
creepy dude this guy is this guy mr.
karen is much more in the wrong than
this lady MS Karen much more in the
wrong men should not behave like that
men should not go up to women in the
middle of parks and start chatting with
them if they don't want to be chatted
with and you know stick around there if
they don't want to be stuck around with
and then start feeding treats to their
dogs that you're trying to lure away
treats that you only have to lure
people's dogs away and then start
filming them that's weird behavior
people shouldn't do that also men should
not humiliate women they should not
humiliate women privately they should
not humiliate women publicly by filming
them and putting that video all over the
internet and then subsequently or
consequently rather ruining her life
that's not very chivalrous behavior that
is the behavior of a society that has
lost the sense of manliness and
gentleman leanness and then let's not
forget most of all he started it this
guy started it because he had to start
carrying around her business and
making a big fuss because she didn't
have her dog on a leash in the park okay
now what people are trying to do what
race hustling mostly white liberal
social justice warriors are trying to do
is make this a whole racial issue I
guarantee you if the case was flipped
they and and this woman was walking
around and this this guy didn't have his
dog on a leash they would be making a
big deal about that they would be saying
oh it's not a big deal to have your dog
on a leash they would this is obviously
a very opportunistic case for people to
push it leftist narrative it's the same
narrative that we see constantly you
know all over the political left the New
York Times is pushing this precise a
narrative listen with us they described
him mr. Cooper 57 a Harvard graduate who
works in communications is hearing that
he's a Harvard Graduate supposed to make
me think he's a more respectable fellow
that is not the way to convince somebody
that that this guy is respectable
hearten I don't think so he's long been
a prominent birder
in the city and is on the board of the
New York City Audubon Society a
prominent birder what is a prominent
birder
oh yes mr. Cooper that well-known birder
that oh yes I see him birding about on
what is birding I guess he looks at
Birds that's what that mean he's a bird
watcher that there are no prominent bird
watchers okay he's a guy here's what
they're saying mr. Cooper who 35 years
ago went to a college in Boston looks at
birds and enjoys looking at birds okay
fine maybe he's a an otherwise nice guy
he doesn't seem like a nice guy from
this video but sure then the New York
Times admits what he did this is
directly from the New York Times quoting
mr. Cooper look if you're gonna do what
you want I'm gonna do what I want but
you're not gonna like it he told her
before he pulled out the treats and
began filming according to his post
mr. Cooper then produced dog treats and
said he said I pull out the dog treats I
carry for just such intransigence he
wrote he's admitting he carries the
treats to get weird with other people's
dogs that's when I started video
recording with my iPhone and
her inner Karin fully emerged and took a
dark turn he said using the name that
has become slang for an entitled white
woman so first of all the people who are
trying to make this a racial thing
should at least admit off the top this
guy is using a racist term the New York
Times is calling it a racist term now it
would appear that the word Charon has
transcended race and sex mostly because
of this guy but from the very beginning
if they're saying that this woman is a
racist surely this guy is a racist -
he's using the term that The Times
admits his racist what's the end result
she loses her job and she loses her dog
hey I'm not joking she got fired from
her investment management firm and they
took her dog away for what cuz she had
this hysterical meltdown in the park
because some hysterical guy goaded her
into it and now she's being smeared as a
racist is this woman a racist I don't
know maybe she is but from the video I
can't conclude that she's a racist why
they're saying that the two pieces of
evidence that this woman is a racist are
that she behaved hysterically on the
phone with the cops and that she noted
several times that he is an
african-american man well she was
behaving hysterically before she ever
called the cops from the very beginning
of the video she says hi I'm gonna get
away from me please
stop it and she's behaving as she's
behaving in a ridiculous way but it's
not as though her behavior changed in
any significant way when she called the
cops she was already behaving
hysterically so that was not
performative and the implication here is
that she was performing this hysteria
for the cops because she wanted to get
the cops there to kill the man because
you know there's an epidemic in America
of racist cops killing innocent black
men which is not true there are
incidents that are sensationalized that
try to craft this narrative that there
is an epidemic of racist cops
slaughtering innocent black men but that
isn't the case the reason that the
stories become so sensational when they
happen is precisely because they are so
rare it is very easy to be emotionally
manipulated particularly by the
mainstream media on issues like this but
these statistics do not bear it out so
there's that first part
gone what about the second one she kept
noting he's an african-american man
again maybe she's a racist maybe she's
not a racist
maybe the definition of racism keeps
changing is the left exploits it so much
I mean now we're told that that only
certain races can be racist but other
races can't be racist I'm not joking
that's what the left tells you so again
I don't even know what definition were
working with anymore but let's just look
at that piece of evidence
she keeps saying on the phone he's an
african-american man she also notes that
he's wearing a bike helmet right when
you call if you're gonna call and make a
police report which was a ridiculous
thing for this woman to do in this case
but both of these people were behaving
in a ridiculous manner so she calls it
makes a police report when you make a
police report you describe the person
that you're making the police report on
right you don't say well he's yeah he's
wearing a blue shirt okay can you tell
us anything else about him no I'm not
allowed to say anything else about him
because if I do I'll be smeared as a
racist and lose my job so she mentions
his race she also mentions that he's
wearing a bicycle helmet is she a cycler
phob does she have a deep-seated hatred
of bicycles or something like that I
don't know why did she include that
detail that would seem to be evidence to
me that she's including descriptors so
that hopefully the police can come and
arrest this man for the high crime of
being a weirdo with dog treats
conservatives need to stop playing into
this nonsense they have to both of these
people behaved badly both of them
behaved in a shameful way an
embarrassing way now only mr. Caron
filmed MS Caron and ruined her life but
they both behaved in a in a silly way
the woman apparently according to
reports is a liberal so I don't exactly
have a political dog in this fight but
I'm just so offended by this guy's
behavior it's so uncivil risk it's so
unmanly it's just so it's just ugly
behavior okay and I think some
conservatives want to prove that they're
not racists to the left which by the way
is not possible because the left doesn't
care whether you're a racist or not they
just want to smear you you know who's
gonna know if you're a racist or not you
that's it do you hate people of other
races and you do you judge them unfairly
based on their race No okay good you're
not a racist good don't worry doesn't
matter what the left says about you if
you know it it's good enough okay
defending this creep does not make you
Rosa Parks all right
ruining this woman's life does it not
make you Martin Luther King does anyone
really believe that this woman should
have her life ruined over this thing
because she was walking her dog and some
creep tried to lure the dog away and
then film Tory humiliated her nationally
no nobody thinks that I don't think the
guy this weirdo birdwatchers should have
his life ruined either I don't think
either of these people should have their
lives ruined
I think they should both take a good
long think sit down have a good long Stu
session on how their lives came to this
point and maybe what's what's wrong with
the way they see the world but I don't
think either of them should have their
lives ruined for this a society that
gets pleasure out of ruining people's
lives like this for ideological
fantasies is sick and ugly I tweeted out
I said hey Twitter mom do you all feel
good now that you ruined this woman's
life and a lot of people responded
mostly white liberals it's always the
white liberals that's like that that
to be the first wave of meanness and
nastiness when it comes to this kind of
ideology but you know other people to
some people responded and said yeah I
feel great I feel awesome I feel so
happy that this woman's life is ruined
that is a sick and ugly society and we
should not want any part of that sort of
thing they're not the only Karen's in
New York that mr. and miss Karen who
will go and live unhappily ever after
are not the only ones there was a big
Karen session in Staten Island we'll get
to that in one second
first though I've got to thank our
friends over at Bambi you know having a
good HR department is the key to running
a great company when running a business
HR issues can kill you with Bambi
however you can change HR from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength your dedicated HR manager is
available by phone email or real-time
chat from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day today you know how much
see how much for $99 a month that is
practically nothing month-to-month no
hidden fees cancel anytime you didn't
start your business because you wanted
to spend time in HR compliance let Bambi
help get your free HR audit today go to
Bambi comm slash Michael right now to
schedule your free HR audit that is
Bambi dot-com slash Michael mi CH AE L
that is spelled BAM to the B EE com
slash Michael M I see h AE L solve your
HR problems today we're moving from
Central Park we're moving all the way
down Manhattan Island we are now
crossing over the water getting into
Staten Island the Forgotten borough in
New York in a grocery store another
another example of men behaving
abominably to women it's funny everyone
thinks that the this story is about race
these kind of Karen stories it's not
about race frankly it's much more about
sex than it is about race because some
woman doesn't wear a mask and the Staten
Islanders in this supermarket lose their
mind starts
obscenities to kick this person out of
the supermarket that's normal behavior
that's a normal society right somebody
walks in to a supermarket does not have
a mascot you know that thing that we all
did up until three months ago doesn't
have a mask on you know the thing that
we were told not to wear because they
don't do anything actually because it
would hurt the health care workers they
said if we wore masks someone does that
and it would be as though this guy
walked in totally naked screaming
obscenities firing off pistols that's
the kind of reaction that he got because
it was a he actually couldn't tell from
the video he was a he or she
regardless whoever the person is I think
it was a [ __ ] looked like a woman but
you know who can tell with these kind of
things regardless this is the kind of
reaction that that person gets something
has gone a little bit off in society
people are a little bit too on edge and
it's not just the pandemic I don't think
I don't think that this epidemic really
helps people in how unaged they are but
I think we were already on edge I think
that the phenomenon of the Twitter mob
the phenomenon of the gotcha video the
phenomenon of I'm gonna ruin this
person's life because they said
something that I don't like that is
indicative of a deeper edginess in the
culture we're just really angry in each
other we just really we just want we
just want to get some revenge for
something for I don't know what because
we got a chip on our shoulder cuz people
are very miserable I'm sure that these
two things are connected there have been
a lot of social scientific surveys in
recent years that show that people are
really miserable they're lonely they're
angry their lives haven't panned out the
way that they think that they should and
I think a big cause of that is because
of the disk and
because it between ideology and reality
the ideological vision that we've all
been sold that nothing really matters
there's no god there's no love there's
no joy there's no nobility there's no
point in serving our country or each
other it's all just a farce we're all
gonna turn to worm food in the end we
need to just pursue our pleasure
ruthlessly and live for ourselves that's
the thing we've been told on the left
and the right and the reality that all
of those things will make us miserable I
think that's that's the disconnect
that's got us all a little bit on edge
well guess what I don't think that you
will feel any better by taking that sort
of anger out on other people
the only way you will feel any better is
if you look in at yourself take a gander
in the mirror and fix your own life
the masks also are just really dumb okay
they're dumb I'm not saying they don't
work sometimes I'm not saying there's
not a place for masks I'm not saying
that in all circumstances you shouldn't
wear masks but the masks generally are
dumb and nobody seriously believes that
they're going to save them least of all
the mainstream media the news media who
were telling people to wear them how do
I know this because MSNBC sent a
reporter out into the field to shame
people for not wearing masks
but the segment didn't go that well when
one of the people that the reporter was
shaming decided to point out that the
cameraman himself was not wearing a mask
the people they're just not worried
about it
how they're not worried about their own
personal safety I haven't met anybody
who is I met some folks actually from
Lake Geneva who lived in the area they
were staying a few miles outside of town
where I were and they said they're
worried about it they're worried about
that second spike they're worried about
folks coming in from Chicago but they'll
quickly add at the same time this is a
place that relies on that business I
think people here want a little bit more
funding when it comes to these programs
so that they could stay close but again
I think people felt like the Supreme
Court made the decision here in
Wisconsin that it was time to open up
but you can see here just around
nobody's wearing them nobody's there you
go including the government yeah okay
striking images Calipari they just can't
they don't
I guess these reporters never took an
improv class so they've got their
narrative right here's the narrative
masks are really important and helpful
and these in irresponsible people
probably Trump voters if you ask me
they're not wearing masks so they're the
bad people and we need to shame them on
national television maybe they'll lose
their job maybe they'll lose their dogs
I don't know but there are really bad
people and then one of the really bad
people points out he goes hey hey buddy
if masks are so important why is your
cameraman not wearing one and and the
reporter doesn't know how to respond to
that because he's just got his narrative
he doesn't know how to improvise when he
gets thrown off his obviously fictitious
script she was yeah and including the
cameraman okay yep just completely
undercut my argument yeah I have no
credibility what so all whatsoever I'm a
hack I'm a liar on television back to
you Katie and Katie goes yep that's
right pretty crazy images out there next
time we'll have to make sure that all
those people telling the truth are kept
far from the camera
they don't neither of those journalists
react to the reality which is that even
NB MSNBC doesn't think these masks
matter that much at all it's just fake
it's just it's just a performance it's
every bit the performance that those two
people on MSNBC we're putting on that's
not me saying that that's them saying
that right they're the ones not wearing
the mask all I can do is observe and
what I am observing is the very people
telling us that the masks matter are the
people not wearing masks you saw this in
the White House briefing the other day
all the reporter very I think was a who
was it was one of the CNN reporters
wearing a mask for all the questions on
camera
the minute she thought the cameras went
off she takes the mask off she doesn't
make the mask matters it's just a
political cudgel it's just a way to
signal her virtue to all of her
followers and to make Trump look like a
mean terrible bad guy the masks don't
look that good Joe Biden wore masks
didn't go well mayor Garcetti were a
mask in the middle of an empty baseball
stadium didn't go that well and this
surgeongeneral told us not to wear masks
right before he told us we had to wear
masks we'll get to all that in one
second there is a whole lot more to get
to especially probably frankly probably
the biggest story of the day which is
the Twitter is now fact-checking Trump
even though Twitter's wrong Trump is
right we'll get to that one second first
I got to thank our friends over at ebb
sleep you know it's very important to
get enough sleep every night but maybe
you have a little bit of trouble falling
asleep and staying asleep well then it's
time to try AB AB is the first and only
wearable drug-free solution that targets
the root cause of sleeplessness which is
your racing thoughts AB is clinically
validated and four out of five users
report falling asleep faster and
improving overall sleep quality AB sleep
is a wearable solution that fits over
the forehead and gently and precisely
cools the forehead to reduce those
racing thoughts to allow people who
suffer from sleeplessness to drift more
comfortably into a deeper and more
restorative sleep it's a pretty amazing
product you put on this headband and it
just sends this cooling stuff right
around you I tried it out I've never
felt anything like it and it's amazing
it's so simple in a way but but you've
never felt it before which is that just
that cooling feeling on your head and
does it really really perfectly we'll
just dull those thoughts help you get to
sleep AB sleep understands the
uncertainty you may be experiencing at
this time they want to help our
listeners right now can get 25 bucks off
your order by using promo code Knowles
and save continue to try ab risk-free
for 60 nights and confirm it's the
solution you've been looking for at
tribe comm slash Knowles let us help you
get the sleep you need and remove the
risk from your purchase t ry e BB
dot-com / Knowles tribe comm / Knowles
use the promo code Knowles to save order
today with everything going on at the
sleep you need and deserve
so Biden wears masks he put a mask on he
went out in public he looked like Bane
from Batman he looks like a really lame
unintimidating doddering Bane from
Batman this is why Trump doesn't wear
the mask statesmen cannot wear the masks
I know but what if the masks help okay
yeah maybe the masks to help then then
even if that were true the president
needs to situate himself in such a way
that he doesn't have to wear the
because just as a matter of optics as a
matter of images and images matter a
whole lot in politics the masks don't
look good and frankly Biden looked good
compared to Eric Garcetti the mayor of
Los Angeles who was giving an address in
the middle of Dodger Stadium this is a
completely empty baseball stadium mayor
Garcetti is standing in the center of
the completely empty baseball stadium
with a mask on what does he think is
gonna happen does he think somebody is
gonna send a heat-seeking guided
coronavirus missile right at him and so
he's gonna have the mask and the mask is
gonna protect him no it's obviously
signaling his virtue in a very
ridiculous way I'm noticing a pattern
here I'm noticing a theme people
signaling their virtue and making
themselves look ridiculous in the
meantime let us not forget the Surgeon
General Surgeon General of the United
States February 29th
seriously people stop buying masks all
caps exclamation point they are not all
caps effective in preventing general
public from catching coronavirus but if
health care providers can't get them to
care for sick patients it puts them and
our communities at risk
this original tweet didn't make any
sense in the first place because what
he's saying is stop buying masks they're
not effective in helping you but they
are effective at helping other people
why is that how's that is there
something different about me is it that
when you graduate from medical school
all of a sudden your immune system
completely changes no I don't think so
didn't make sense in the first place but
don't forget the experts in the lab
coats the political authorities right
that top guy told us don't buy masks
February 29th then May 23rd quote as our
communities reopen wearing a face cover
E is something we all can and should do
to protect each other so no matter how
you're spending Memorial Day weekend
wear a face mask covering went out in
public comment with a selfie and
encourage others to do so - which one do
we believe well you would say we got to
believe the most recent one because
that's the newest one based on the
science
hasn't changed the science I know you
think what you don't think if you're
listening to this show you probably have
a decent grasp on this but many people
think that science it's like something
that changes with total precision day by
day now we know everything that ever
came before today was wrong but now we
know for certain the eternal scientific
truths of the universe that's not how it
works they're gonna change their mind on
masks again they're gonna change their
mind on a whole lot of things again
there you cannot simultaneously say that
we can export outsource all of our
politics to the scientific lab coat
experts because they are so invariably
correct and also they contradict
themselves on a daily basis you can't
have those at the same time perhaps the
more reasonable thing to do would be
take the advice of scientific experts
and other sorts of advisers take that
advice and then engage in the process of
politics which is what we're all doing
in self-government debating what kind of
society we want to live in what kind of
risks we want to assume how we want to
get along together that's probably what
I would do that's how politics is really
supposed to be engaged in but people are
trying to cut that off left and right
including a Twitter which is now trying
to cut off the political process by
declaring an unprecedented declaring
that President Trump is wrong and
ironically they're saying he's wrong
about things that he's actually right
about and they're wrong about we'll get
to that in a second first though I've
got to tell you about backstage which is
happening 4:00 p.m. Pacific 7:00 p.m.
Eastern that's coming up tonight so get
excited for that also don't forget you
get one tumblr that's pretty good
what if I told you you can get two
tumblers that's right some great news
the double tumblr is back but it's only
available for our most exclusive
membership tier which is all access the
all access membership tier is our
premier level of membership you know you
get you get the Q a as you get exclusive
editorials you get bonus hours at Ben's
show you get an ad for your website you
get everything head on over to daily
wire.com slash subscribe to join all
access get 15% off with coupon code
Knowles Kim wles right now that is daily
wire.com slash subscribe see you there
we'll be right back
this is a big deal President Trump is
being fact-checked on Twitter but as you
know fact-checking is a relatively
recent political phenomenon I mean
actual fact-checking has been going on
for a long time but this journalistic
phenomenon of fact-checking is probably
at this point about ten years old and
what fact checks really mean is they are
left-wing opinion columns that pretend
that they are objectively indisputably
true and so that's the fact check that
refutes right-wing opinion columns or
opinion pieces you see this in the
Washington Post they never call it the
counterpoint they never call it the
left-wing point that was caught the fact
check even though the fact check is
nothing more than a left-wing piece so
they're doing this now on Twitter
president Trump sends out a tweets this
quote there is no way zero that mail-in
ballots will be anything less than
substantially fraudulent mail boxes will
be robbed ballots will be forged and
even illegally printed out and
fraudulently signed the governor of
California is sending ballots to
millions of people anyone living in the
state no matter who they are or how they
got there will get one that will be
followed up with professionals telling
all of these people many of whom have
never even thought of voting before how
and for whom to vote this will be a
rigged election no way
so what Trump has just made is not he
hasn't even made a statement about what
is currently happening or what has
happened in the past primarily he's
making a statement predicting what will
happen in the future if there is an
unprecedented policy that people are
trying to push as the unprecedented
response to the unprecedented
coronavirus pandemic right there would
be no way if we're talking about mail-in
voting across the country there would be
no way to gauge how how that works out
because it's never happened before we've
never had something of that scale so he
makes his prediction Twitter decides to
ding him with a fact check and it's a
it's just a little blurb underneath it
says get the real facts get the facts
about mail-in ballots with an
exclamation point you've got to pay
attention to this and
click on it says Trump makes
unsubstantiated claims and you know this
is basically this thing this is BS don't
believe it except and I something tells
me that the White House just has to know
about this they have to time these
things because they know how the news is
gonna play out the very same day the
Trump makes this point that there will
be voter fraud which there will be
having to do with mail-in ballots we get
a story out of West Virginia Thomas
Cooper mail carrier in Pendleton County
was charged yesterday in a criminal
complaint with attempted election fraud
according to US Attorney Bill Powell
Cooper 47 years old is charged with
attempt to defraud the residents of West
Virginia of a fair election this is
based on the fact that in April the
clerk of Pendleton County received
twenty twenty primary election kovat
nineteen mail-in absentee requests from
eight voters on which the voters party
ballot request appears to have been
altered so they see they get a bunch of
these ballots where it looks like
something changed and now it turns out
that this mail carrier Thomas Cooper was
trying to commit election fraud just one
guy on just one day that happens to be
the day that president from tweets this
and Twitter fact checks it sure looks
like Trump's claims are substantiated to
me and don't forget this is we're just
talking about election fraud having to
do with the mail system there are other
types of election fraud to non-citizens
voting lack of voter ID people voting
multiple times busing in from other
counties and other states all this sort
of stuff has happened okay all this sort
of stuff happens regularly we have many
cases of well over a thousand documented
cases in recent years but even if we did
this is kind of the problem with voter
fraud is you don't get a lot of
documents on what actually happens so we
do have a lot of evidence that it's
happened and presumably the problem is
much much larger than that it this is a
big issue the Twitter is fact-checking
Trump because Twitter and Facebook and
Google right in all these places have a
monopoly over the flow of information on
the Internet I'm not saying they haven't
monopoly over
information per se meaning there were
still conservatives who are on Twitter
right Trump is still on Twitter so he
can say his point of view but they have
a monopoly over the flow of the
information because whenever Trump gives
his point of view they can smack a
fact-check here and say nope
really that's not that's not true even
if it is true that's a very bad
situation
we should not permit these decidedly
left-wing big tech monopolists to
control our flow of information and our
elections we haven't allowed that to
happen in other ways that we communicate
we shouldn't allow it to happen here I
you know I'm as skeptical of the
government as anybody but I am more
skeptical of big tech because at least
the government has some slight
accountability to me and there is no
reason in the name of I don't know in
the name of any kind of slogan the free
market that we need to allow Twitter and
Google and Facebook to control our
elections it's not even you you wouldn't
even make a free-market argument for
that
but some people have suggested that sort
of thing no no way buster I'm not
letting some Silicon Valley weirdos
control my politics because of some
misguided interpretation of a principle
that I actually hold speaking of
misinformation turning to Washington
State not too far from Silicon Valley we
are now looking at the corona virus
death tally and you know certain things
are a little bit wrong like for instance
the New York Times yesterday published
this piece with virtually all of the
victims of coronavirus then you look
down the list and you see the sixth name
on the list did not die from coronavirus
he was murdered and left in the woods in
New Jersey oh yeah well that's not
coronavirus I wonder how many other
issues there are here well we got one at
Washington State Washington State's
Department of Health has now confirmed
that among the coronavirus death tally
they've included people who died from
other causes including gunshot injuries
which means I guess the virus is now
picking up guns
we should all really be afraid that
certainly would terrify me if this
Chinese virus decided to arm itself with
with firearms the Freedom Foundation
which uncovered this reported in remarks
made during a telephone briefing that do
H officials acknowledged knowingly
including knowingly including multiple
deaths caused by gunshot wounds in the
state's kovat 19 fatality count a
reporter asked the Washington governor
and failed presidential candidate jay
Inslee about it and Jay went on the
defensive what sort of criteria are
being used to mark these fatalities well
it's from the official documents the
best information we have from the local
health officials that's the best
information we have I'm not sure the
relevance of what that group I guess
they're saying that that would make it
887 dead that's okay and we should not
act responsibly if there's only 887
people instead of a thousand people I'm
not sure I understand that logic I don't
think anybody does understand it who
knows any of these families who've lost
a loved one so I don't think that's a
particularly persuasive argument even if
it was true yeah that's not a persuasive
argument because that's not the argument
that anybody's making that's the straw
man that you're making cuz you got
caught lying he's saying what so people
are saying because we got the numbers
wrong pretty significantly by double
double-digit percentages that what that
we shouldn't take the virus seriously I
don't think that's a good argument yeah
of course it's not a good argument
that's why nobody's making that argument
we're just pointing out that you got the
numbers wrong and you got them very
wrong and you did something
extraordinarily dumb which is include
gunshot victims as coronavirus deaths
and it's making us question question
your credibility on everything else
having to do with this virus also
because you guys have been wrong about
this from day one you've been wrong
about the models you've been wrong about
the predictions you've been wrong about
the efficacy of masks you've been wrong
about putting sick people into nursing
homes you've just been wrong
everything basically so yeah we question
your credibility here and of course jay
Inslee goes on the defensive he he
fights this straw man then he attacks
the people who are who did the actual
research who did the investigation and
who had their suspicions confirmed by
the Department of Health right so it's
but the Washington State Department of
Health is confirming that this mistake
happened and jay Inslee writes it all
off as a crazy conspiracy theory the
conspiracy theories that are fanning
people's efforts to go out and do what
this group did argue that 887 deaths
just not something to be worried about
is really disappointing to me I've heard
people things say things that are from a
different planet and it's very
unfortunate that some folks in public
life have fanned the flames of
misinformation in that regard because
it's dangerous it's dangerous to
people's health I have no reason to
doubt the fatality numbers that we're
using in the state of Washington right
now the problem is you got some people
out there who are fan in these
conspiracy claims from the planet Pluto
and it's just disgusting what they're
trying to say have all these crazy deep
state malarkey
who are kind of suggest that this is not
a problem in our state I find that hard
to accept with the number of dead in our
state so that's a problem and I hope it
gets resolved so nothing he just said is
true not one single thing where's the
fact check where hate Twitter Twitter
where's your fact check on this
demagogue and liar jay inslee he said
that people think that 887 dead is
nothing to worry about nobody said that
not a single person has said that you
said jay Inslee is the only guy who said
that nobody thinks that 887 dead is not
something to worry about we think that
you jay Inslee are something to worry
about because you've lied about this and
you've gotten everything wrong and then
you're smearing your constituents who
showed that you
got something wrong as some kind of
crazy conspiracy theorists your own
Department of Health admitted that the
so-called conspiracy theorists were
right and that you were wrong but
there's no humility here and this is
something you've got to pay close
attention to this around the country
none of these politicians are going to
admit that they got this wrong they
can't do it they are dispositional e
incapable of that kind of humility of
that kind of self-awareness narcissism
is a professional risk of politics and
at the high levels it's nearly a
requirement they're not going to admit
they got it wrong they're gonna double
down and they're gonna get nasty and
they're gonna get vindictive and they're
gonna try to ruin people's lives and
they're gonna try to smear all of their
critics as conspiracy theorists even
when the state health department's admit
that the conspiracy theorists were
correct they're good this is what the
left does all the time you see it on
Wikipedia now over the past couple of
years one thing that they've managed to
do is for a huge number of prominent
conservatives start they've included
this phrase conspiracy theorists to on
their Wikipedia page they never put
conspiracy theorists on James commis
Wikipedia page because after James Comey
said that there might be a Moscow
prostitute urine tape with Donald Trump
in it based on nothing that's conspiracy
theory they never put a conspiracy
theory mark on any of the left-wing
journalists Facebook pages Jake Tapper
Jim Acosta any of them who peddled the
Russia lie and hoax for three years they
never do that but they will put
conspiracy theorists on right-wingers
just to convince people not to listen to
them that's why though we're gonna put
fact checks when President Trump says
things which actually are true so-called
fact checks it's just a way to signal
don't believe this person don't listen
to this person it's gonna get very
vindictive the the only way that we're
going to be able to get back to anything
even resembling normal society as we
once knew it in the way back ago days of
three or four months ago is by pushing
fearlessly not afraid of what they're
gonna call us not afraid of the
consequences which can be dire not
afraid of the digital consequences which
can be dire they know they won't just
change your wiki they won't just fact
check your Twitter
they'll put videos of you all over the
Internet just like that creepy Karen and
Central Park did - MS Karen in Central
Park right that is the kind of vitriol
that we're talking about we are in an
election year this is all geared toward
the election the ridiculous responses
from governor's the day by day more
ridiculous responses of governor's on
lockdowns that no longer have a
scientific justification the fact checks
from Twitter the rhetoric the vicious
rhetoric coming from guys like jay
Inslee about citizen groups that are
trying to correct the record it's all
the focus uncertain highly charged
emotionally manipulative incidents in
this country to divide people on issues
like race and sex it is all geared
toward November that is only going to
get more intense don't let them fool you
don't let them whip you up into that
frenzy do not become either of those two
crazy people in Central Park and don't
get pleasure out of ruining people's
lives that's the trap that's the trick
don't let them dupe you all right that's
our show got a lot more to get through
we'll do it tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
fenders hair and makeup
Nika Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the Michael Knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Cleveland
[Music]